so und jetzt haben wir noch ein video
für sie das gerade wie irre geteilt wird
ein video was in diesen minuten einfach
wirklich um die welt geht es geht um die
pressekonferenz des präsidenten von
chile bis dahin dachten wir auch
langweiliger geht es doch gar nicht aber
auf den präsidenten guckt hier gleich
auch kein mensch mehr dann plötzlich
crashte ein comic held die szene gucken
sie sich das mal
mit starrem blick hält chinas präsident
hatte seine rede gar nicht einfach denn
auf kniehöhe entfacht sich ein echtes
superhelden abenteuer ein kleiner knirps
im superman kostüm umkreist den
staatsmann per lauf war der helm xxl das
rote kay flattert im wind und es geht
drum
rum und moritz verzieht keine miene die
lage in chile ist ernst ausschreitungen
mit der indigenen bevölkerung soziale
ungleichheit und erst am wochenende
wurde die neue verfassung abgelegt
trotzdem steht der kleine helden knipst
den negativnachrichten die show die welt
fragt sich wer ist der junge denn
superman rollte auch schon auf dem weg
zur wahl ohne durchs bild es soll sich
möglicherweise um ein pflegekind der
präsident mutter handeln
[Musik]